the president is on his way back to
Washington after spending the holiday
weekend at his Florida resort about an
hour from the Parkland shooting scene he
has been busy on Twitter posting about
many topics from Oprah Winfrey to the
Russia indictments the Kremlin is
weighing in now on those charges as well
dismissing them as proving nothing about
Russian government involvement of
correspond at Kevin cork is outside the
president's Florida compound tonight
good evening Kevin evening my friend
listen what a difference a day makes
right just one tweet about Russia today
from the president one of just two
tweets all told and that's a dramatic
departure from what we saw over the
weekend when he was virtually tweeting
non-stop about the Russia investigation
it was a digital deluge a defiant
president Trump's weekend tweet storm
ran the gamut of topics but the Russia
investigation clearly was front and
center if it was the goal of Russia to
create discord disruption and chaos
within the US they have succeeded beyond
their wildest dreams they're laughing
their asses off in Moscow the
president's foray into the Twitterverse
was just his latest attempt to draw
contrast between his constant refrain of
no Russia collusion with the ongoing
Russia probe which despite the recent
indictments of more than a dozen Russian
nationals he is ongoing predictably
today the Kremlin rejected the notion
that they were interfering with
America's elections Authority it looks
like accusations have been made but no
evidence was presented so an Americans
say that Russia does not acknowledge
obvious facts for us these aren't
obvious facts yet even a member of the
president's own cabinet wasn't spared
from the wave of Russia related
criticism case in point this comment
from its national security adviser and a
security summit in Germany and as you
can see with the FBI indictment the
evidence is now really incontrovertible
and available in the public domain the
president chided mcmaster writing forgot
to say the results of the 2016 election
were not impacted or changed by the
Russians whether or not votes were
changed or the election impacted by
Russian interference is still anyone's
guess however the fact that the
indictment alleged the Russians have
been targeting the u.s. since 2014 drew
this question from the president
day Obama was president up to and beyond
the 2016 election so why didn't he do
something about Russian meddling exactly
what the former president and his senior
intelligence cadre knew about Russian
meddling long before the 2016 election
calls into question who could have or
should have done something to stop it
Obama was in a very difficult position
and did not want to make it appear that
he was favoring Hillary Clinton maybe he
should have done more but while mr.
Trump asserts the new indictments mean
he's in the clear some warned that may
not be the case congressman you've seen
the intelligence do you think that this
indictment suggests that it's a case
closed no collusion and no of course not
but this is a president who claims
vindication any time someone sneezes
speaking of the Obama administration
former Vice President Joe Biden said
they were walking a constant tightrope
over how much or how little to say about
what they knew with with regard to
Russian meddling but there have been a
number of critics John in particular in
the Trump administration who have argued
they've said decidedly too little far
too late John
Kevin core grapping up his weekend with
the president down there in Florida
Kevin thanks so much